insgesamt gibt es über 160 verschiedene
währungen in ca 195 verschiedenen
ländern es ist also kein geheimnis dass
zehn euro super unterschiedlichen wert
in verschiedenen ländern haben aber wie
sieht das konkret im vergleich aus wie
unterscheidet sich das leben und was
bekommt man für zehn euro in deutschland
um was im büro die afrika lasst es uns
gemeinsam herausfinden
[Musik]
vorwerk mir ist absolut bewusst dass wir
als reiche westliche länder dazu
beitragen dass dieser unterschied so
extrem ist natürlich haben aber auch in
politische entscheidungen der länder und
viele andere faktoren auswirkungen der
ruf in diesem video geht es nicht darum
das ganze zu bewerten oder so ich möchte
einfach nur den stand der dinge
verdeutlichen und es euch bewusst machen
ich habe gerade links in die video
beschreibung gepackt bei denen ihr
vielleicht ein bisschen mehr infos dazu
bekommt wie das ganze so zustande kommt
der plan war einfach ich brauchte
jemanden der in einem land lebt in dem
zehn euro deutlich mehr wert sind mit
ein wenig suche konnte sich colin finden
der im grunde legt also habe ich mich
mit ihm in verbindung gesetzt und wir
haben das ganze fest gemacht ich sende
ihm zehn euro was umgerechnet zum
zeitpunkt der aufnahme circa 22.000 boni
frank waren beide zeigen was wir für ein
frühstück mittag und abendessen mit
diesem geld kaufen können und was
vielleicht sonst noch so möglich ist mit
dem verbleibenden geld jetzt stellt sich
aber die frage wie habe ich das geld
sicher um die halbe welt geschickt nicht
weil ich konnte ihm nicht vertrauen
sondern weil im internet viele gefahren
lauern hier kommt cyberghost ins spiel
ihr wisst wahrscheinlich bereits dass
sie beim surfen im internet immer dem
zugriff auf eure informationen
ausgesetzt seien und ihr überall einen
fußabdruck hinterlassen cyberghost vpn
bietet hier gegen aber schutz indem sie
ihre ip und eure daten verstecken so
dass ihr sicher und anonym surfen können
ohne dass jemand weiß was ihr online tut
nicht mal cyberghost selber weiß was ihr
macht einfach gute pr unternehmen das
schon seit 16 jahren aktiv ist also eine
menge erfahrung hat und apps für alle
möglichen plattformen pro bietet also
ios android windows mac eigentlich alles
was ihr euch vorstellen könnt ihr dort
über 6100 verschiedene server in über 90
verschiedenen ländern also eine menge
möglichkeiten um eur location zu
switchen und für eine sichere
internetverbindung zu sorgen
ihr könnt das ganze über eine
subscription mit sieben verschiedenen
geräten machen das ganze hat mir
geholfen dass ich collins zahl um den
zahlungsdienstleister geschickt habe von
dem ich vorher noch nie gehört habe dem
ich also auch just vertraue cyberghost
hat aber für eine stabile und sichere
internetverbindung besorgt abseits davon
ist natürlich möglich dass ihr depot
werden auch für sachen nutzt die
streaming und serien schauen es gibt
also manche serien die in deutschland
nicht zur verfügung stehen wenn ihr den
vpn benutzt zwischen location einfach in
ein land wo diese serie verfügbar ist
und der zugriff auf alle weltweiten
serien außerdem ist der service super
einfach zu nutzen ihr braucht also keine
erfahrung auch wenn vpn vielleicht wie
irgendwas klingt was er nicht versteht
über den link in der video beschreibung
und nur über diesen link in der video
beschreibung kommt ihr zur cyber ghost
und kriegt 83 prozent auf das drei
jahres abo drei monate geschenkt das
sind im endeffekt dann irgendwie zwei
euro im monat
hierfür diesen vpn bezahlt außerdem
bieten sie eine 45 tage geld zurück
garantie falls ihr nicht zufrieden sein
sollte wovon ich aber nicht aus die ich
danke vielmals für den support und jetzt
viel spaß mit dem video 10 euro genau
das war mit 15 jahren ein stundenlohn
bei meinem nebenjob eigentlich ziemlich
gut bezahlt für einen job ohne
ausbildung neben der schule
das geld hat für kleine käufe und das
tanken meine des rollers gereicht und
damit war ich super happy ich habe
früher alles im stundenlohn umgerechnet
also bevor ich mir was gekauft habe habe
ich gerechnet wie viele stunden ich
dafür arbeiten muss mittlerweile ist das
leider nicht mehr so und ich gebe ohne
mit der wimper zu zucken zehn euro pro
mahlzeit jeden tag aus der luxus und die
bequemlichkeit haben mich eingeholt
mit zehn euro hat colin bruni die
möglichkeit jede mahlzeit außer haus zu
essen und für was er sich entscheidet
und wie viel das ganze gekostet hat
zeigt er uns jetzt
für 4500 wohnungen die frank oder
umgerechnet zwei euro kommt so colin
also ganz entspannt beim bäcker
frühstücken und sich richtig können ich
in deutschland kann natürlich nicht wie
sonst auf dem weg ins büro beim bäcker
halten und mir irgend ein belegtes
brötchen und ein café für fünf bis
sieben euro kaufen weil dann wären nicht
mehr genug geld für mittag- und
abendessen
ich weiß ehrlich gesagt gar nicht warum
ich das morgens schon immer mache ich
könnte mir auch einfach die zeit nehmen
und frühstücken
aber die bequemlichkeit und der luxus
haben mich wirklich einfach so sie
eingeholt dass ich selbst mein frühstück
nicht mal selber zubereitet ich habe
mich für ein all time classics
entschieden porridge mit april so komme
ich natürlich super günstig weg und habe
dann im laufe des tages die möglichkeit
irgendwann mehr auszugeben und mir
irgendwas zu können aber schon verrückt
zu sehen dass ein paar tausend kilometer
entfernung so einen unterschied machen
können ich fange jetzt parallel
vielleicht sogar schon an mein
mittagessen zu kochen weil das kann ich
natürlich auch nicht bestehen wir haben
keine küche im büro also muss ich mich
morgens schon darum kümmern und das ist
fertig zu machen um es mit ins büro zu
nehmen während ich mich nach dem
frühstück direkt auf dem weg ins büro
mache da ich durch corona maßnahmen in
deutschland quasi nichts anderes machen
kann und meine tage momentan immer
ziemlich gleich ablaufen sieht es bei
collins schon ganz anders aus und macht
sich also auf dem weg in die stadt um
ein bisschen shoppen zu gehen ich
brauche natürlich gar nicht drüber
nachdenken zum einen wegen koma und zum
anderen weil ich natürlich nicht genug
geld haben
neben der sonnenbrille die circa 1 euro
gekostet hat kauft kommt auch noch ein
armband für denselben preis das ist
völlig verrückt und für uns
wahrscheinlich komplett unvorstellbar
weil selbst wenn wir irgendwelche
günstigen brillen bei irgend einem stand
in der stadt kaufen würden wäre das auf
jeden fall deutlich mehr als zwei euro
während ihr hier seht wie sich köln auf
den weg in einen park macht wollte ich
nur kurz sagen dass ich super happy bin
placement partner für dieses video
gefunden zu haben weil ich konnte so
noch sehr sehr krass für seine mühen
bezahlen kann was bei mir wäre es
kostenlos gewesen ich vermeide es aber
gerade jetzt kurz vor weihnachten extrem
unnötig nach draußen zu gehen da ich
gerne meine oma und weitere angehörige
zu weihnachten sehen will deswegen
beschränkt sich mein entertainment den
ganzen tag aufs internet und hier ist
mir noch mal was bewusstgeworden plant
ein internetfähiges gerät und ein
vertrag kosten geld auch nicht gerade
wenig wenn man diese beiden komponenten
aber hat sind die entertainment
möglichkeiten nahezu unbegrenzt alle
standard social media plattformen sind
kostenlos und bieten wirklich
unbegrenzten content man kann gar nicht
so viel schauen wie jeden tag online
kommt ist es möglich sich weiterzubilden
neue dinge zu lernen einfach nur
irgendwelche sendungen zu schauen oder
sogar kostenlos zu zocken wenn man mal
darüber nachdenken was für möglichkeiten
wir haben ist es wirklich unglaublich
und bei ihr dieses video hier gerade
seht erfüllt ihr wahrscheinlich beide
komponenten also internet vergisst gerät
und internetzugang wenn man mal so
darüber nachdenkt ist wirklich verrückt
in was für einer zeit wir leben und was
für möglichkeiten wir haben es wäre ja
sogar potenziell möglich mit einem handy
einfach ein business aufzuziehen
und die hat jeder von euch wenn ihr
dieses video gerade sehen könnt jetzt
geht es aber erstmal weiter mit dem
mittagessen
kohl gegen den manager edf
bevor wir aber sehen was kommt für den
abend geplant hat erst mal zu meinem
mittagessen neben dem frühstück fange
ich an mein mittagessen zu machen aus
den eben genannten gründen kann ich
natürlich nichts bestellen und das auch
nicht im büro machen also muss ich mich
morgens darum kümmern
aber das ist kein problem ich habe mir
das ganze mittagessen freue ich mich
immer meisten drauf unter gönnen max und
ich uns auch eigentlich immer richtig
dass das jetzt so aussieht ist die
letzten drei monate nicht mehr
vorgekommen weil wir halt immer
bestellen was halt absolut dummes aber
so ist es nun mal jetzt bin ich gespannt
inwieweit mich dass zufrieden stellen
kann und ob das vielleicht option ist
vielleicht auch für die nächste zeit
denn eigentlich will ich nicht mehr so
viel bestellen und auch im vergleich zu
collins mittagessen stinkt das hier
deutlich abkühlenden saß im restaurant
hat drei verschiedene sachen auf seinem
teller gehabt also bei ihm saß nach
einem absoluten traum aus bei mir sieht
aus wie neben der kantine
wenn es wenigstens warm wäre es sind
halt nur mit pesto so was was soll da
falsch laufen weil ich komplett
vergessen habe wenn ich heute abend beim
abendessen nicht komplett auf den putz
haut dann kann ich mir das hier jetzt
genehmigen das ist aber dass eine der
sachen für dich super viel geld ausgeben
davon trinke ich vielleicht drei am tag
oder so wenn ich am kiosk kaufen sind
das sechs euro und jetzt kommt er
wahrscheinlich krasseste unterschied
während bei uns gerade neue corona
bestimmungen vereinbart wurden und man
abends draußen natürlich nichts machen
kann sieht es im grunde ein wenig anders
aus
pressekonferenzen kamen herstellen
marien und st
[Musik]
[Applaus]
und auch zum abendessen wieder nichts
was besonders ist nichts was fans ist
und nichts was ich bestellt haben aber
genau das schlägt sich natürlich auch im
preis wider der sich auf verläuft aber
ist erfüllt seinen zweck und ich fühle
mich sehr gut damit denn ich habe heute
nicht wie sonst zwei mal am tag bestellt
und unendlich viel geld dafür ausgegeben
und so sieht meine abendplanung für
heute abend aus ich gehe nicht wie
kolumbier trinken ich gehe natürlich
nicht feiern
das ist krones ich nicht möglich und das
hier ist für mich die perfekte
abendplanung momentan ja natürlich könnt
ihr auch dazu kommen jeden abend bin ich
livelink das in der video beschreibung
vielen dank dass du das video bisschen
an geschaut hast wenn ihr das video
gefallen hat was wir gerne like da
vergisst nicht den kanal zu abonnieren
damit du das video am donnerstag oder
sogar das nächste am sonntag nicht
verpasst vielen dank auch noch mal ein
cyber ghost check den link in der video
beschreibung aus wenn ihr eine sichere
und stabile internetverbindung haben
wollt vielen vielen dank für den support
wir sehen uns die tage